hey folks this is international master
David Cruz for chess comm and today I am
delighted to be doing a feature on the
greatest chess player of all time Garry
Kasparov who also happens to be my chest
role model not necessarily life role
model that's two different things but
the most incredible chess player ever in
a real inspiration to me with his chess
of course whenever you talk about the
best ever there are people with
different opinions so I'm doing this
video and it's my opinion that he's best
um garry kasparov has some possible
evidence of the fact that he's best for
example the highest rating ever he was
rated 2851 and also the most months as
the number one rated player he was the
number one rated player from 1986 to
2005 consecutively 20 entire years and a
total of more than 250 months in his
career so yeah those are some good
evidences another is that he has the
longest streak ever of first or tied
first places in professional tournaments
of 15 serious tournaments and he also
became the youngest world champion ever
at the age of 22 after an epic battle
with Anatoly Karpov now look at this
picture of Garry that I'm showing you
and realize what is so amazing about
this picture this is Garry Kasparov at
age 17 at his first Olympiad
representing the Soviet Union he was the
youngest player ever to represent the
Soviet Union at the time this was one
year before he would start his streak of
winning every single event he played in
for a decade okay he was only 17 he was
one year away from starting this streak
and what I see in this picture is just
an incredible amount of energy and sort
of intensity and knowledge about chess
you see that the game hasn't yet started
but he's staring so deeply into the
center of this board and when I see that
I see all this energy waiting to be
unleashed and
next ten years of just non-stop brutal
decisive chess games he didn't quite
torch everyone the way Fischer did at
his peak winning candidates matches with
scores of 6-0 but I think that
Kasparov's opposition was a lot stronger
so in any case that's Gary right before
he started his streak and before he
became the number one player in the
world and now let's turn to the chess
board and see one great example of his
proficiency as a chess player this game
here is not his most famous game nor
necessarily his best game is just one
which I feel is really representative of
what's great about his play so he's
playing white here against Grandmaster
Nigel short who once challenged him in a
match for the world championship
although this game is not from their
World Championship match and they're
playing a main line of the nimzo-indian
defense and this is a line here that
Gary Kasparov was great at playing he
played many good games or several good
games in this line several which I
remember including an epic one against
Anatoly Karpov for the World
Championship also a good one against an
ond so in this position White has a weak
C pawn and as compensation for it he has
a nice bishop pair and sometimes Black
has trouble developing the queenside
because of the pressure along this
diagonal and this is a variation which I
also play a lot to this day and that's
because of Gary of course so the game
develops a little bit further and now
you see Gary is going to start seizing
the initiative and that is one of the
things that really distinguishes his
chest from the best chess that was
played before he came along he really
showed how to use the initiative in
incredible ways so here he starts off
the wildness with this pawn sacrifice c4
getting rid of the weak pawn before
black can put a knight on B 6 and then
c4 he fills that square with the black
queen with a pawn sack and he doesn't
have any tactical follow-up he just
defends his night and he castles and now
Nigel short plays h6 and here
continues to build on his initiative see
he can't have predicted everything that
was going to happen in this game when he
played 95 and c4 sacking the pawn even
the greatest player in the world
couldn't have predicted when playing
Knight b5 and see force acting upon I
you know the intricate way in which
every single thread in this game would
lead you know 20 moves down the road
with these kind of sacrifices but he was
strong enough to have the feeling for
doing that of knowing when to go for
something like this when to say like
yeah I can give up a pawn just to keep
the Black Knight out of c4
and you know stuff will keep coming if
he challenges my dark-squared bishop as
black does here with h6 and the bishop
has no good square right on because he
doesn't want to trade it for this night
to know that you know probably all have
Bishop takes h6 in this kind of position
once he gets here to see how he might be
able to follow up Bishop takes h6
so anyway Bishop takes h6 itself could
be sort of a stock chest theme right
where you give up two pawns get your
queen near the opponent's king but note
he's already given up one pawn so you
won't have much comp for the piece and
how he executes this is also very
important the next move has to be for
cutting the black Queen off from the
Kings side so black moves the knight to
e7 because if it goes to f6 then after
Queen h6 the knight won't be solid on f6
right it'll be hanging and hard to
support it there so E for Knight goes to
e7 now another important move kicks the
Queen with his rook while it's here so
the black wing goes off to bad square
and the white queen comes into the black
King okay but still not clear what
White's decisive attack will be and now
he follows up with a rook lift
threatening rook g5 and rook age 5 black
defends swings the rook over Queen c2
now of course he could sack his rook for
the night and get a draw by perpetual
check and good players often like to
know if they're sacrificing a lot of
material that they have at least a
perpetual check that way if they're
calculating for a win and they can't
find it they can say like oh shoot that
doesn't work and and just at least get a
draw still but Gary goes for more he
brings his knight back defending the
rook and
chasing the Queen the Queen attacks the
knight and now he brings a new piece to
attack on the Kings side just wave after
wave of attack and here he comes
and the black Queen comes back and now
another incredible move from Gary E 5 he
doesn't take tonight with his pawn
because it'll let the Queen over to
defend instead he first adds his bishop
to the game and black defends and he
brings his bishop in and here he gets
back one of the two pieces that he's
sacrificed and he still has one extra
pawn forward and continuing attack
against the black King this is where
Nigel short could have defended pretty
well with Bishop c6 so it's not the
greatest game ever I'm not claiming that
it is but it's still really
representative of Gary's incredible
style of just pushing pushing pushing
so here Queen h7 check is a great move
and that's why black needed to move the
bishop off the back rank so that in this
position white wouldn't have checkmate
in the endgame on so queen h7 check is
played nigel has to move his king and
now he comes back here and the point is
to attack with rook to h5 even this is
hard to see how it's working but by now
I'm sure Gary was able to calculate
everything he arranges this rook trade
and then his last piece the rook manages
to participate from the other side of
the board and after the knight blocks
trades the rook can't take because it
would open up the attack avoids Queen on
e7 right on so he takes with his queen
and now he swings his queen over to the
other side of the board as well these
are just the kind of moves that are
really hard to predict but I'm sure Gary
calculated all of these and here the
game ended because he is simply going to
checkmate black black resigned here but
the game will end with rook check rook
blocks and Queen h4 and amazing how his
pieces swung all around the board right
so the things that we can take from
Gary's play dynamic being willing to
sack me allah tension is in the position
and following it all the way through
from move 5 or 10 and
came all the way to move 40 or 50 seeing
the entire board and swinging your
pieces around and calculating like a
beast garry kasparov the greatest ever I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm